Les amis nous sommes en 1930
Nous sommes une femme qui s'appelle Scarlett et qui travaille pour un journal qui s'appelle
The Revenge. Aaron Williams est le redacteur en chef de ce journal, à savoir
Le boss. Et nous devons trouver dans les archives de ce journal de quoi le mettre derrière les barreaux.
... et je parle pas de celui que t'as le matin en te levant.
Ok c'est parti l'enquête commence !
"Pandorica"... et c'est un jeu français !!
Ouais ouais moi j'suis français ouais j'suis fier ouais
C'est parti pour la plus grande enquête.
Oh putain ça plaît d'entendre du français dans un jeu vidéo,
surtout une si belle voix hein.
Hééééé ! Elle joue bieeen !
Putain !
On est loin d'un connard de Squeezie là hein.
On va avoir 5 jours pour trouver des preuves
pour montrer que Aaron Williams est un gros f.d.p.
et qu'il mérite la prison.
Voici l'interface du jeu
Voilà ! On a donc ici des documents,
celui-la c'est celui qu'on vient de voir
OK, donc là y a écrit absolument n'importe quoi hein y a rien à lire.
Un document est égal en gros à une vidéo d'archive.
Ici on peut marquer des notes si on en a besoin...
c'est faux...
Ah ici pardon, voilà.
On peut déplacer les documents pour les trier dans l'ordre euhh
qui nous importe.
Et y a 23 éléments à trouver !
Comment on fait pour découvrir de  nouveaux éléments ?
On tape tout simplement un mot clé,
on va commencer par le nom du rédacteur en chef...
j'ai oublié ma pipe c'est hyper grave c'qui se passe.
"Aaron Williams"
OK !
Et ici qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
On a des petites cartes qui résument
le rôle de la personne au sein du journal
Donc je pense déjà le premier truc à faire ça va être de marquer
chaque nom d'employés
dans la barre de recherche
pour en savoir un peu plus sur eux
vous voyez y'a Lance, y'a Amelia, y'en a beaucoup hein
putain ça va être une longue vidéo mais franchement on va vivre une sorte
de putain de film, ça va être cool !
Ok on va regardé la vidéo qui est apparue en tapant Aaron Williams dans la recherche
C'est partie !
Mais pourquoi ça ?
Ok
Ok donc ce mec rencontre l'équipe du journal pour la première fois il s’attendait pas à une réponse et il en a eu une
Est-ce qu'on à pas ça carte à Mat ?
Matthew Winsmay ! Ok
Matthew Winsmay
Rien ?!
Mat ?
Ah ok !
Donc ça on l'a déjà vue
Putin il nous à donné trois truc !
Donc ça c'est logiquement la suite de la scène qu'on vient de voir on va la regarder
Hummm...
Ok donc le mec gratte direct l'aide de Mat ok ok ok ok
Cette situation là on l'a jamais vue et l'autre non plus on dirait une sorte de réunion on va regarder celle là avant
Ah ! Mat c'est violent genre
Mat il lui a fait un vrai truc de pute
Et du coup ils signent la lettre de démission
Ca va me dire pourquoi ils démissionnent
Ah ! C'est horrible on sait que c'est un criminel mais on sait pas ce qu'il a fait !
Putin j'ai hatte de trouver
Heureusement que je suis un inspecteur réputé
Et là je sais que vous avez envie de savoir ce qui c'est passé  vous êtes comme moi maintenant
On va taper le nom du journal
Wo !
Ah ! ça sa doit être la suite de la réunion
Ok donc ils démissionnent tous et en plus de ça ils veulent faire bidé le journal de leur Aaron
On va bien s’organiser contrairement à quand tu fais tes devoir le mercredi
On va les classer par scènes comme ça
Il y à peut-êtres un autre document qui viendras compléter cette scène
Ah ! Nouvelle situation et nouvelle situation
Commençons par celle-ci
Anne Bonny !
Ok donc ça sa remonte à la création du journal je pense
Ils cherchent un nom pour le truc !
On va faire ce que j'ai dit au début on va marquer le nom de chaque employer
Dimitri !? Qui est Dimitri ?
Oh ! on a un troisième moreau de la réunion ça m’intéresse
Chatterbox !
Je vais le mettre dans les notes et on iras le voir après !
Celle là on la pas vue non plus regardé
C'est la suite..Ah non c'est pas la suite puisque c'est un autre mec qu'est assis
Mais tu n'a toujours pas de barbe Aaron éspèce de mytho..pardon !
Police d'écriture ok ! Pas la police heuuu...Non !
Ok donc lui il est chargé de rédaction ok donc il a un bon poste Dimitri
On oublie pas tout à l'heure Chatterbox on va le cherché
*bruit de clavier*
Oh putin il y a que du nouveau là
On à la suite de la réunion putin ça sa me plais
Tribune ok !
Au Tribune ok c'est encore un autre truc
Et Emie du coup on sait pas qui c'est ?
On l'a pas vue encore
Bon moi je suis intéressé par Chatterbox car il voulait leur rapporter un truc
Qui est Chatterbox ?
Une première vidéo
Surtout parcequ'elle connait du monde
*rires*
Oooo ouai !
Elle veut prendre cette meuf pour son images pour pouvoir mytho en toute confiance
Donc c'est quoi ça ?
Jaloux cet homme est jaloux
Aaaaa !
Ils sont frères et soeurs !
Ok j'avais noté quoi d'autres ? Tribune !
On à que le truc de tout-à-l'heure
C'est à que a devient compliquer Ah Non ! On à pas encore noté tout les perso
Qui est Alan tient
*clavier*
Ah ! C'est nouveau ça !
Pourquoi vous voulez êtres discret ?
Ok donc Alan il est chargé de la communication c'est un mec qui pèse qu'a 600 000 contacts
Lance Aisney
Matthiew déjà vue
Dimitri déjà vue
Scarlett déjà vue
Aaron déjà vue
Là on est dans la merde
Moi le truc bizzard c'est Mat
On sait rien de lui regardé
Il est rentré en 1933 et on sait pas ce que c'est sont rôle...bizzar
Ca sa veut dire que je suis nul
Et que je fait des recherche qui bide
Tu sais pas à qui tu parle gamine
Scarlett Aaron
Ah !
Il y en à un qu'on a pas vue
Ooo !
Donc avant il y avait Jack un rédacteur en chef et Aaron la remplaçé
Aller Jack BIM ! Qui est Jack ?
Vous avez trouvé suffisamment de documents importants aujourd'hui voulez-vous finir la journée ?...ok !
ouai très bonne idée meuf !
Jour 2 tout le monde sauf Aaron
On a que 5 jours je vous rappelle j’espère que je vais pas me foirer
Ok ok merci merci c'est adorable !
Ton père pesait de ouf
*Desol j'ai pas compris*
Donc je journal avait un père qui s’appelait "The Commander" qu'il à fait fermer pour ouvrir "Revenge"
Donc son père je pense c'est Jake l'ancien rédacteur en chef...Je sais pas
J'ai tapé Jake Williams et j'ai obtenue un CD
Ok donc le journal avant devait s'appeler le Anne Bonny's Revenge
Est-ce qu'on va pouvoir trouver le "Anne Bonny's Revenge"
On va voir si il y a pas quelque chose
Ah ! on la déjà vu il devait s'appeler comme ça avant du coup comme maintenant c'est juste "The Revenge"
En tapant "Moss" j'ai eu Amy 3 Ouiii !
C'est la suite de l'interview
Hummmmm...
n'oublie pas que tu peut taper un mot combiné ou un mot rechercher hier puisque il y a de nouveaux journeaux aujourd'hui
Oh ! Nouvelle vidéo en tapant le nom de "Junie"
En gros c'est weekyleaks le truc ils prennent des documents que des gens trouvent et publient tout en vérifiant que se sont des vrais
On va remettre Alan voir
Ah ! Il y en a un qu'on a pas vue
Hitler !!
Et voilà on a un truc Ah Ah !
bon l’enquête avance un peu mais là c'est la phase la plus dur on est dans le flou
Mais tout va devenir clair dans pas trop longtemps je pense
Ok donc c'est la suite
C'est weekyleaks mais à l'époque quoi ! Sous forme de journal
Dimitri il y a du nouveau ?
Oui !
Retour à leur engueulade !
Oooooooo !
il y en à un qui avait déjà essayer de quitter le délire
Dimitri à voulu se barrer
Donc elle reproche à Aaron de trop snober son équipe et de pas faire attention à eux voir même de s'en tamponner les couilles
Bon là on est dans la merde j'ai tapé tout les noms de l'équipe dans la barre de recherche et sa na rien donner
Putin mais ils parlent tous mal du journal alors que ça na pas l'air d'être désastreux
Et je comprend pas ce qui fait qu'ils soient entrainé dans un truc qui leurs plais vraiment pas
A part le fait que Aaron est un connard je vois pas pourquoi ils réagissent comme ça
Là il y a un CD qu'on à pas écouté sur Aaron
Oh la la il est chiant
Roo Putin !
C'est beau
Et bennn
Moi je pense que tu ma pas donné de mots clés *rires*
Merci pour l'indice
J'ai tapé journaliste ça nous à donnez un journal qu'on a pas vue
Oh ! Archives !
Volé les archives de sa famille
On avait vue une vidéo ou elle disait "Tu ma fait voler les archives de ma famille"
Putin j'ai envie de savoir ce que c'est ces fameux archives là !
J'ai tapé le mot "peur" et sa nous a donnez deux nouveaux journaux dont une situation qu'on ne connait pas
Putin c'est bien ça !
J'comprend même pas la problématique fait chié !
Voilà
Il à dut avoir un putain de procès
Et là on va taper "Edward Ford" et la mon gars c'est la fin
De l'enquête *rires*
Je pense on va tomber sur pas mal de truc
Oui oui oui oui !
Ah c'est la suite de la conversation
Putain on se rapproche là !
On commence à tout reconstituez dans le bon ordre
Ah j'ai pas vue ça !
Incendie on va tapez incendie
Ok j'ai eu de la chatte !
En tapant États-Unis puisque Edward Ford si est réfugié
Et je tombe sur un document qu'on à pas encore vue
Georges Montaurier
Reed And Crown
Tais-toi ! Tais-toi !
HaaaaAAAA !!
On peut passer à la journée d'après
Donc là on a les preuves qu'ils ont falsifier un document avant de le publier
Aaron il a raison si je puis me permettre
C'est ouvrir la porte à de gros problème
Aller fin de la journée putain
T'aurais pus les amener plus tôt on aurait gagner une journée
Oh Putain !
Georges Montaurier !
Et BIM !
Il y en a une qu'on a pas vue
C'est la même réunion
C'est une "Fat" réunion sérieux
D’accord il y a la liste des mecs qui se sont fait agresser vulgairement effectivement c'est un peu umilliant pour eux
Je suis d’avis à modifier le document puisque là on empêche des mecs d'avoir des problèmes
Hèèèè !
Faut drès trouver le nom du mec qui à lancé l'arnaque
Procès ?
Aaah en tapant procès on à eu des choses là
*Liser le document à l'écran je prend ma pause café*
*Slurp*
*Oh ! Putain c'est chaud !*
*je saurais pas contre un petit sucre*
*Non pas de lait je déteste le lait !*
*Oh vite il va se remettre à parler !*
Donc Aaron il a pas tord dans le sens..
C'est un bon dilemme là
auquel ils font face
Ok nouvel extrait de cette réunion
C'est super dur là !
En tapant "note" j'ai eu des choses
Et on a la suite de la réunion !
Ok ok ok ok...
Non !non pas du tout et c'est une excellente idée
Ah en tapant "source Aaron" j'ai trouver un truc
Ooooo ! POPOPOPO !
Il change petit à petit Aaron
il veut vraiment que sont journal soit comme il le voit,soit parfait complet ect...
Il en vient même à violer ces principe
Aller fin de journée journée suivante !
Oh oui Junie Schimt il manquait un truc qu'on avait pas vue
Oh non le vendu
C'est pas grave on le met en prison et on va en prison avec lui
Qui est cet "Adams"
On a une autre partie de ce moment
*Lis le document c'est (encore)l'heure de ma pose café*
Oh non il est froid maintenant !
*Beuwark ! C'est horrible le café froid !*
Vite mon stylo !
Donc le mec fait de la magouille avec la politique ce con !
Oh ! The chatterbox column le revoilà ce journal
J'ai tapé procés revenge
Mais qu'est-ce qui c'est passé putain !
Chatterbox BIM on trouve deux trucs
Ah histoire d'amourette ça !
Oh merde ! C'est la *indéchiffrable* journal qui a annoncé les fiançailles du mec
Oui en tapant fiançailles on tombe sur ça !
Oh ! elle est amoureuse c'est mignon !
En tapant fiançailles Aaron on a un truc !
Ra putain c'est hardcore !
Le mec pour gagner des points auprès des gens il est près à mytho
Il y a de quoi le briser devant les gens
Fiançailles Hitler Revenge
Je fais n'importe quoi !
J'aimerais bien la suite de cette conversation là
Qu'est-ce que le mec à fait pour qu'il gratte un truc
Edward Ford il y a du nouveau peut-être ?
Oui !
Ah voilà de quoi inculper la famille Williams
Mais dit-moi ce que j'oublie !
Tu voit pas que je vais perdre mon emploi à cause de toi !
En tapant vrai j'ai eu ça
Aaron regarde direct Scarlett !
Attend comment elle à répondu en mode hésitante
Il me manque un troisieme document !
OH !
En tapant publié je suis tombé sur la partie qui nous manquait !
C'est ça qu'ils ont fait !
Hummm...
*musique d’enquête*
J'en peut plus !
Les amis cela fait maintenant 2 heures et demi que je joue à ce jeu
Je suis à ça de la solution c'est avec Adams il y a un putain de scandale
Il veut gratter un peu de voie d'électeur en demandant à Aaron de lui faire de la pub dans son journal
Mais on sait pas ce qu'il à fait de mal pour qu'il puisse faire ça
Il doit manquer une ou deux vidéo et putain !
J'ai marquer tout les mots de la langue francaise
Mercie d'avoir regardé toute la vidéo sa veut-dire que sa vous à plus
Et que vous vouliez élucider le truc comme moi
Même si on à fail j'ai adoré ce jeu je vous invite à télécharger le jeu il coute 5 € je croit
Et essayer de résoudre ce truc
Je suis dégouter j’espère qu'inspecteur Squeezie aura des élèves qui dépasserons le maitre
N'hésiter pas à aimer la vidéo Bla bla bla...
La vidéo est tellement longue qu'on est plus que 10 et vous c'est 10 mec je vous kiffe
A une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien désoler d'avoir fail chao tout le monde peace !
Muzikeu rigaulautte ;)